hello everyone and welcome back to the
tata steel masters edition 2020 it's a
vladislav quality versus Fabiano Caruana
I run 12 already started but we stated
we were gonna cover another at least
another game from round 11 to check out
the standings after 11 rounds so this is
the one I decided show as it features
well a long to read theoretical struggle
in the opening but it's also a very very
nice line in the rule Lopez for black so
I'm sure gonna enjoy it and you might
even decide to use it in your own games
and also if you're enjoying the two
photos to the left they are by the
official photographer Alan alameen of
the tata steel tournament so I will put
a link to her twitter profile in the
description below so you can check out
some of her other work that being said
let's check out the game
Kovalev opens with E for now with ePHI
by Fabi not interested in testing for d4
against Fabi as teen he knows from the
World Chess Championship that Bobby is
able to play against the d4 very well so
with a 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 the rule opus is on the
board we have a 6 more fees defense push
up to a4 and the knight to f6 we have
castles and b5 by Fabi Bishop to b3 and
now a very ambitious line with black
gush of the c5 and this is where the fun
starts
ideal ideas like Knight characters on e5
don't really do anything for white if
anything they will only help black for
example the four characters captures in
these six and black black can be very
happy if f4 c5 pushes the Queen back
let's say queen here knight c6 and you
might have some problems with with the
backwards D pawn but if there should be
Bishop e6 for example d5 you you should
you should be okay and it's all been
tested before so that's why no one plays
it so we have c3 here by white this is a
move to the secret that seeks advantage
d6 and now a4 and this is uh why why
it's such a nice line here rook to b8 it
will basically come as a pawn sacrifice
but you'll see why we've d4 by kovalev
be six now the rook is no longer
guarding the pawn here a captor son b-58
captors in the night to a three and this
is where the fun starts
so here in some games the Bishop to g4
has been played but the main line is
castles this is what Fabi goes for and
Kovalev grabs the pawn so just the
knight capture some b5 you don't have
any discovery since then I can just
capture back it's not a problem so a
white is up upon for the moment but
Bishop to g4 black will get excellent
development and well both are still have
the bishop pair but black the bishop
repair is extremely strong here we have
rook to e1 this is still all main line
and now Bishop captures on f3 giving up
the bishop pair but forcing wife to ruin
his pawn structure this is why you
sacrifice the pawn on the Queen side and
there actually is one game where Queen
captures on f3 was played and white was
able to win that game but called have
not interested in in testing fabi's
theory knowledge so G captures an f3 and
now Knight to h5 making room for the
Queen to enter game also the night is
coming to f4 you can play f5 if you want
to so a lot of ideas here and here the
main move is king - h1 which frees the G
file for white rook but here we have f4
by Kovalev it's it's a move that has
only been played once Fabi captures an
eye for we have Bishop captures on f4
and then now he captures an f4 and now
this exact same position has been
reached also in the tata steel
tournament but in the challengers
division in 2017 between Eric Hanson and
Guin Jones where Hanson played Bishop to
a4 and going Jones was able to win that
game but it's not that bishop day for
it's a bad move it's also a one of the
engines recommended moves but we have
Kings to h1 it's a new move and it's
where the angel prefers this move more
than a hand since Bishop 34 so we might
say that a coil is still within his
preparation so what do you what do you
do here so far be continuous Knight to
e7 preparing to bring the knight over to
g6 testament this pawn on f4 and it is
the engine stop replied the King H one
so far be still
well within his theory push back the
situ and not Knight to g6 we have before
sort of fighting against the c5 but
Bobby decides to push c5 right away well
not right away first he kicks away the
night with c6 we had night the a3 and
only now sorry I just have to check on
meadow for a second he's doing some
weird stuff yeah there's some food on
the table so I'm just checking if he
didn't go get that food but he didn't he
was only trying to do it but yeah okay
nice day three and here now Fabi
executes c5 with big afters and c5 d
captors and c5 and now you could try
something like B captures and c4 but you
don't want to ruin your nice pawn center
here you might try dd5 but the immediate
d5 you free the e5 square for five is
Knight Bishop to Bishop to a5 also an
idea I'm just opening the going for that
c3 pawn which you will be unable to move
it to c4 due to the ribbing and e1 so
here instead we have night the c4 he
goes after Fabi strong leadership and
the nopsi captures on d4 we have Knight
captures and b6 rook captures and the CT
after sandy force so for the moment it
seems that coil have is doing very well
in this theoretical struggle rook to d6
going after the d4 pawn and now look the
a for defending we have Knight to e5 by
Fabi you cannot capture of course
because rook captures and d1 so you're
preparing knight c6 to add a third
attacker to the d4 pawn f3 ending out
knife to c6 and this is a well where
it's really it really tends a co-ed of
much lower run time than Fabi
he plays a 5 here d5 is the engines
favorite and it kind of does make sense
but once 95 is played those pawns are
not going anywhere
for example Ruby g1 you put a nice rook
here King Queen to f6 you you free the
room for the group to be developed this
rook is coming to c6 and well it's it's
just a much
much better position for black white
doesn't really have any any clear plans
here so instead what do you do here and
also after the rock moves you can also
play something like King h8 g 5g 4 and
well maybe even create a past F pawn so
black would be better here so instead of
doing this which is the engines favorite
but again it's one of those cases where
were you as a human really really don't
want to play it even subconsciously you
might even know that d5 is the strongest
move but you don't like it and you don't
want to play it against Fabi so e 5
instead giving up a pawn here and
preparing Bishop to c4 to cement this
pawn on f3
so rook captures on d4 rook captures on
d4 Knight captures on d4 and now rush of
the e4 defending the pawn here and you
can never push a 5 to do to do to the
characters of um Poisson
so Queen to h4 by Fabi now not allowing
the Queen to skip the the back rank
because the the rook would be hanging so
rook the g1 you want this rook here
either way and now rook to d8 the Queen
is guarding the rook from age 4 so this
night when the knight moves some deadly
discoveries are possible like maybe
night Knight to f5 opens up a discovery
to the Queen followed by Knight to g3
trick could be deadly
so of course Corvette moves the Queen
and now g6 you don't want to worry about
your captors and g7 and it's it's just a
useful move so rook the g4 pushing
fabi's Queen back Queen e7 and now comes
who Rock captures an f4 not an easy
decision for cooperative most likely
there are some other things to consider
like for example Queen to c4 is very
interesting because after Queen captures
an e5 you kinda have Queen Bishop
captures and g6 but you don't
for example H capital G captures with
check King h8 and now Queen captures on
here
it seems very nice but it doesn't work
and I'm sure you know why it doesn't
work
even without pausing the video not
because of Queenie 1 if Queen e1 then
you just block and you're just winning
because of well you can just check mate
black in a lot of ways Queen g7 mate
Queen h5 mate but after night sorry
after Knight to f5 you got Jesus
h6 there are no mates here and the next
when the road comes down it's just game
over but it is interesting for example
Queen f6 check captures captures and now
if the knight moves you even capture
this one then it's a rook and two points
against the rook and Knight but you do
have rooked d5 defending the knight and
after Kings you want King g7 pushes the
rogue back room b6 and now with the DF
point surviving it's just much easier if
you attack well even if the the ponies
attacked at some point you can also
defend it from here so it's not a
problem at all but it is interesting
Queen to c4 move so co-ed have for the
lack of a better move place rook
captures on f4 and now Queen captures on
e5 with rook back to h4 and now Knight
eastex by Fabi the night again can now
come to g5 to f4 we rook the h3 Knight
to f4 and now rook to g3
it's a solid setup for white but Fabi
plays rook to d2 and it was in this
position unmoved 36 that vladislav Caleb
resigned the game well he's not only a
pawn material-wise but a clockwise he's
down to three minutes and Fabi has some
40 minutes on the clock and another
thing there's no more white can play
like any move you make it's just not
good enough
I mean there's no good move for you to
make like if you play some like Ruby g1
Queen Queen B to just goes after mate if
you want to defend mate it's very hard
to do like Roo g3 you may be vacated the
g1 square for the king but after
characters captures you just move the
rook and now Queen h2 is mated there's
no way to block this the night covers
both of these squares so even blocking
with the rook is impossible
there's just no defense against Queen h2
you're just gonna have to give up some
pieces and that's that's about it now
but after rugby to co-ed have resigned
tough tournament for kovalev but Fabi
prolongs his lead as in in round 11
Magnus drew his game against the angst
of Duda with with the black pieces and
with this this means that
Fabi expands his lead to a full point so
these are the standings after round 11
Fabian so lead with 8 out of 11 Magnus
with 7
11 a soul so second place and then with
six point six and a half Wesley so
followed by Jordan van forest and young
shift of Duda then Vishwanathan Anand
with five and a half on each giri daniel
du bois Valadez a Fallujah and Vladislav
Artemyev all with five and a half with
five Jeffrey sharing with for Nikita
fatigue of Anu Enki and in last place
after losing yet another game at
Vladislav Kovalev so yeah yeah that's
another game from round 11 like we like
we said I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Bob Marine Maryam village
dog McNab Victoria the Lully Lewis and
bus guarding for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel masters we're going into the
penultimate round today checking up on
your wonderful suggestions continuing
the morphe saga and so on whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday